hi this is presh talwalkar
in this video i'm going to teach you a
fun way to multiply numbers called the
slide method of multiplication
let's say you want to multiply three
thousand and twelve by one thousand and
twenty-one
let's do this problem with the slide
method of multiplication
the first step is to reverse the digits
of one of the number
so we're going to take the number 3012
and reverse the digits
so we write down a 2
then a 1
a 0 and finally a 3.
the next step is to take the other
number and we're simply going to copy
down the digits
when you actually do this in practice
you're going to write it on another
piece of paper
for this video we'll just put it off to
the left so we put 1021 off to the left
and now comes the fun part where we're
going to slide the number across
so we're going to take 1021
and we're going to slide it so that the
first digit lines up
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to multiply vertically
and add
so right now we only have two numbers
which is two times one
and that's going to give us our first
digit of the answer which is two
we slide it across
and now with the digits that are
vertically lined we multiply two times
two which is four
and one times one which is one
so adding up four and one
gets us the net next digit which is five
we slide one more time
and now we multiply vertically and add
so two times zero is zero
one times two is two
and zero times one is zero
so in this step of the sliding we only
have two
we continue to slide
so we have two times one is two
one times zero is zero
zero times two is also zero and three
times one is three
so we add two
and three
to get five
we continue sliding we have one times
one is one
zero times zero is zero and three times
two is six
so we add one and six to get a seven
sliding once more we have zero times one
is zero and three times zero is also
zero
so that gets us a zero
and now finally we have three times one
is three
we put in some commas
and that's our answer three thousand and
twelve times one thousand and twenty one
is three million
seventy five thousand two hundred and
fifty two
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory
you can also catch me on my blog mind
your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker or you can
get my ebooks at amazon
and a video i think you'll like and a
book is multiply numbers by drawing
lines so check it out